YOU THOUGHT 5.000 EPISODES
WASN'T ENOUGH?!
SAY IT WITH ME Br0s!!
HAPPY WHEELS!
hAPpy WheELs!!!
HeCk YEaH!!
We're back baby
For another 100 episodes of happy wheels
We're starting a new-
I'm not- just full of shit- I'm just gonna play once XD
You guys just couldn't have enough, could you?
YoUr FaNtAsiEs could NEVER be quenched?
Well here I am
[Funky music]
Aaaaahhhh [In echo effect]  XD
The sweet sound of happy wheels
It just brings back all the memories
Fetus Pewds: Anyways are your ready?
MiNeCrAfT ft. Felix's laugh
I missed you, Happy Wheels
[Fake Sweedish Accent] Let's frickin do this
So let's go by 'any time' and sort by 'rating'
HARPOON DODGE!1!?!?
I'm glad to see they're innovative because I've
NEVER PLAYED A HARPOON DODGE!
Harpoooon Dodge 2!
oh, okay, we're starting with harpoon dodge 2
oh, easy
3...2...1 Go
easy
that one's easy.
I did it. I did it.
My God I'm so scaared
is this- oh God this is actually- oh God
Not another one
I'm still alive... I'm still alive
iTs FiNe
I'm choking myself
*maniacal laughter*
oh, that does not look good!
*more maniacal laughter*
It's okay, guys
I'm a LITTLE rusty
but I'll be- but I'll do it- I'll do it, I'll do it, I'll do it!
Control, shift, eject
I eject alright
( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
So you wanna go as flat as possible
ah, f-
You wanna go dolphin
That's all I know, that's all I remember
oh, oh
see this dolphin?
oh, God
*maniacal laughter, for a third time*
I'm actually having fun playing Happy Wheels.
oh, God
It's hard, it's hard!
That's my head
( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Oh, we got a metal penis, everyone
Is Happy Wheels gonna become like Minecraft?
Will people just start playing it unironically again?
I think I know what I need to do, I think I know what I need to do
oh God, oh alright, so
you wanna make sure...
that's uh...
OH!
DAMMIT!!!
*maniacal laughter for a fourth time*
I AM SO TERRIBLE!!!
Ah, I'll take it, I'll take it, I'll take it
I may have lost my foot
but I'm STILL ALIVE!
NOPE!
SEAL OOH!
OH!
yeah
yeah, I'm still alive God damn it
oh, oh oh, well that's- this is gonna hurt
OH I DODGED IT!
OH! [Feminine voice] Awesome~
Oh, oh, oh seal mode (dolphin or seal mode, whichever will it be?)
there it is, ooooh
God damn it, I'm good
When's it get going? This is easy.
Oh, this is easy.
classic.
EASY! Bring it, Happy Wheels
I got YEEEARS of experience
YEEEEARS
Alright, they're dropping down now. I don't know why
my foot is coming with me.
see ya later, foot
live a good life.
Nani!?
What is this? Have they finally added checkpoints? No.
Thanks for playing, I hope you liked it, have a nice day
Have a nice day (x3), everyone
Harpoon dodge one, of course
Cannot have enough of this
eeeeasy
Oho! Aha!
Give me one where I have to jump, I have the pogo
OHHHH!!1!!!
No, I'm still alive (x3)
I'm still alive!
I'm still alliivee~
What a shit f- kind of bends up a bit, I control dodges
Okay, that's good to know
It went through my knees
Alright, they- I think they got my knees
I dunno what to tell you, guys
Guess it still comes through
did it
BOTTLE FLIP!?
Nani!?
bottle flip!
OH MY GOD!
I'm very bro (?)
NOOOB
Ah, WAT
Alright, what if we threw- what if we threw backward
OH!
AH!
[Whiny voice] Come on man, come onnn
*grunts in swedish*
sniper
I'm a sniper, guys.
this is it
OHHH!
oh.
this is it, this is it.
THIS IS IT
*le gasp*
AAAAHHH!
*tropical sounding music plays*
[childish voice] create a meme face!
Whhaaat?
*mandatory GFuel reload, use code Pewdiepie*
AWE HELL YEAH MEME FACE
select language
uh, I already failed
clearly, memes are only in spanyish
spanyish? that's right.
hhhaz click akey si elikay estay (at least he tried)
ahhh, muy byan (bien)
soy biEN, soy boy
here we go
we'll do the cereal meme, I love that meme so much
alright, what's next?
ah, the eyes, okay
UHH
oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah
feliz
FEEELLIIIZ
AHHHHH
sugoi, kawaii
BURGER!?
BUUURGER
can't wait 'till I see what my troll face is gonna lo-
cara- carakando (with italian accent?)
I mean, it's impressive how people did this
There it is
estay es t-tu meme
Sorry to interrupt this video, just want to give a big shout out to my bois,
El garo (finna skip captioning the ad)
ROPE SWIING
I LOVE ROPE SWIIING
*undertale papyrus theme plays*
here we go, rope swing, WOOOH HOO HOO
first try, zero deaths, let's frickin do this, rope swing, baby
WOOOH!
WOOOH! ah.
Hell ye
Huuh yea
*grunts in swedish three times*
AH, AH! (this is why you can't watch pewds in public)
here we go
YEA-
I'M STILL ALIVE! I'm still alive!
woohoo!
YEAH!
Let's go ho ho
*grunts* ugh, fck come on
ARGH!
AHHH
No! No! Grab, grab, grab, grab
Can I still grab with my handicapped arm?
That is questions
ah
bye, arm
it's been a pleas- (congradulations PTSD)
OH!
ahhh
dammit
WOO HOO HOO HOO
AH! awe.
there it is.
perfection
so, how do I go here without dying?
still alive, baby
oh! We hit it (x3)
and then, now, we drop it.
drop it bew new new (tune of Sporty-O's Let Me Hit It dubstep)
oh god, oh god, oh god
oh god, what's gonna happen
pi-pixel on
MY GOD, IT'S MINECRAFT
OH MY GOD IT'S MIIIII
WOOOO
am I supposed to go here? Okay, I'll go.
[Italian accent] super mario!
[Italian accent] but why-uh me-uh
[Toad voice] OH, OHH!
IM RIDING NYA- *giggles*
Is this guy making the- all the maps?
No one else is making this map?
pterodactyl screech
nothing like winning in fetal position
oh, ultimate glass break
[Raspy voice] TIIIIIIMMMM
DUH DAH DUH
[Raspy voice] DAAAD
*unintelligible raspy baby noises*
AHH
I can still do it!
Someone, help me adjust my spine
*grunts*
SON, THAT'S NOT MY SPINE!
Well, the comedy has definitely increased
It's funny, because now it's ironic!
[Raspy voice] Shut up, dad
*uninteligible raspy gibberish*
*three loud groans*
[Baby voice] don't leave me, dad!
Alriight
NAH!
ah fck, I ejected ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
god damn it
how is this the top rated?
There it is
*yet again, random raspy noises*
*angry, deeper, raspy noises*
*grunt*
how do I eject my son?
Please dont eject me, I love you dad, I love you, da da
Why am Ieven playing this?
fcking garbage.
AHHH!
AHH!
fack
[Baby voice] Hell yeah, now it's time for that sweet ass (pedo)
grip it, slap
slap.
number one most subscribed, everyone
*indecipherable deep, raspy nonsense*
*grunt*
[Baby voice] hell yeah, you're doing awesome, dad.
JUH JUH!
YEAH, WE MADE IT!
oh, we did it dad THANK YOU SO MU-
GO! NOO!
NOOOOO!!!@1
Da ha ha ha had
num num num num num num num, delicious
I can finally eat
Well, oh well that was Happy Wheels
hopefully everyone is as happy as happy wheels
brofist!? (I better get one for captioning)
On 100 mil, baby (baiting me, you sick fuck)
See you guys tomorrow.
BYEEE
Also, check out merch, link in description